my guest tonight is the co-creator
co-producer writer and voice of over 30
characters on the Netflix animated
series big mouth he also has a new movie
out called Olympic dreams please welcome
our good friend mr. Nick Kroll Nick how
are you I'm good Conan I'm I do I have
to say I miss being behind a curtain
right now talking to a teamster hearing
that intro and then walking out and
awkwardly waving at a studio audience
who's mildly pleased to see me so this
is uh I'm doing I'm but otherwise I'm
doing well I'm very happy to be
communicating hey you know what I want
to do before I forget which is I got
invited to I think like seven satyrs
virtual satyrs for Passover I'm curious
did you participate in a Passover Seder
I did actually
we did one last night with a at 3:30
p.m. with my family who's all in New
York my sister Dana and her husband
David and their family put on a whole
play the Passover flouride Passover yeah
and they all stayed in frame and it was
like watching uh it was like watching a
great production of the exodus from
Egypt yeah and the original Exodus was
done on zoom' I'm told yes what did you
do on your end I made this thing called
Carosa which is a corrosive charoset
corrosive yeah there you go
there it is you are an Irishman who's
been in enough writers rooms with Jews I
got on gorgeous so if Carosa tis like
apples walnuts some some wine cinnamon
and it sort of chopped up into a fine
thing and it's supposed to symbolize the
bricks that the Jews enslaved in Egypt
used to build the pyramids and you mix
it with more or although the as the
Hebrew had been Mahal can you know oh
very good with just a coarse radish and
you make a little sandwich out of it you
eat it on matzah I so I made that last
night
to impress my family like look at what a
good Jewish boy I am and then I woke up
this morning and my my eyes are coming
back but I had an allergic reaction to
the walnuts yeah I could tell your eye
even I can tell your eyes look a little
like a doubt yeah no my eyes are bugged
out I so I had an allergic reaction to
making Carosa at an online seder which
may be one of the more Jewish things
said on earth today alright now I want
to bring up something you did something
that sounds like it raised a lot of
money but also sounds like something
spectacular I really wish I had seen
this which is you did a feeding America
and you did it with a table read yeah of
a script with the entire cast of big
mouths I would love to see you guys do
that
it was a live table read over zoom with
with basically our entire cast and yeah
and we we did it we did it on zoom and
and it went straight into YouTube and
throughout we just tried to amplify
feeding America which is a great
organization that is trying to help
everyone in need who needs food and they
support over 200 food banks around the
country and there so we were able
through that a live broadcast on YouTube
and then it's still up on YouTube if
people want to see it check it out yeah
it's it's it's a great idea and you guys
have such an amazing cast that and it's
also one of those shows where it's fun
I would imagine because I am a fan of
big mouths and I know a lot of you guys
personally but to see you do the
characters and then be able to imagine
the characters as they're animated would
be really fun I would yeah it was great
it was and I think honestly it was
pretty early in into this whole thing
and it was I think nice for everybody to
get together just even over zoom and see
each other and do something that felt a
little lighter and and also for
hopefully people out in in in the world
like just to give them something to
watch yeah I think we're extraordinarily
lucky to be working in a weird business
where we can still do what we do from
home I feel very grateful about that I
mean yeah
you and I it can still make this
ridiculous foolishness and and be you
know keeping people employed and working
with our people over Xoom men we're
extraordinarily lucky we're very lucky
to get to do that we are not most lot of
people are not having that experience
and so I'm I'm very I feel very grateful
and I'm you know just trying to figure
out ways that we can help other people
who are not in in this privileged
situation for any number of reasons so
yeah yeah I want to ask you
we're gonna go from the sublime to the
absurd you you posted a picture on Super
Tuesday it was a photo of you when you
ran for class president
it's amazing to look at this picture
because you look exactly like your
character on big math yeah yeah we did
the people will say that all the time
when I post this book oh my god you look
like the kid from big mouth I'm like
yeah it looks it's big it's based on me
and he's got the big ol forehead and the
big old lips and it's I don't know
certain people's faces look cartoonish
like when I look at the picture you're a
cartoon of you yes it's like it looks
absurdly like you just like that little
picture of me looked like me yeah and
I'm like what is it we're just like
these like cartoon people it's no wonder
we ended up doing what we do you look
like a you know like a potato with red
hair and I look like a little pickle
with big big lips or both insulting
caricatures of our heritage I know well
that's I I just posted this thing on
Instagram of I guess there's a people
are obviously trying to figure out ways
to fill their time and so there was a
caricature contest some guys assigning
people for playing Raw every day so I
woke up on Instagram one morning to like
I don't know 20 caricatures of myself
and I look like I mean I just like my
features are was so big and what am I
the first joke I ever one of my first
jokes on stand-up that I did was some
people tell me I look like Jeff Goldblum
and other people tell me I look more
like a Nazi propaganda cartoon of a Jew
and do these caricatures you are like oh
boy now you posted a photo from your
prom night look at the hair on you this
is incredible incredible locks yeah on a
young Nick Kroll and I'm curious how was
that prom night did you have a
satisfying prom night it was not great
it was not a great prom what happened my
friend said I was I had like a pre
cocktail party thing for all the kids in
my grade to come to my house and none of
my friends came and then we did the prom
itself was fine and then we went and saw
jazz in New York City then I thought it
was so cool and all of my friends did
not like it was not a cool - what was
your problem
did you ever get prom no I didn't go to
prom I it's a long story but I ended up
not going to prom and I ended up going
to a I went to a store that sold potted
plants and fertilizer cuz my dad needed
fertilizer so I ended up loading a bunch
of bags of fertilizer into the back of a
really crappy station wagon getting
covered in fertilizer dust because he
wanted me to plant these shrubs in the
backyard and then I was driving down
route 9 back to my house and I stopped
at a stoplight and next to me was a
limousine and the window lowered and it
was this girl I really liked and this
guy was taking her out and I was waving
to them it's a long story but I did not
go to prom and I reread a shitty prom
fertilizer you know we didn't you need
you didn't need to say fertilizer you
know kind of get in close I'm gonna get
in real close I can't because of my
allergic walnut ice I can't get it too
close to the camera now listen you speak
with the youth of America through day
you do you do and you've been at rooms
everywhere you've been asked to stop
yeah well my question is what do you
what do you think is I mean so many
young people so many 17 and 18 year olds
are gonna miss their prom this year what
do you think how are they gonna get
through that well I'm
I think we're I'm working on I'm working
on something actually to try to get to
figure it help kids who are missing
their prom I'm working on something
right now for real but I think like
here's what I'll say it's like whether
you get your prom or not and all these
poor seniors who are socially distance
from each other in their like senior
spring it's a highlight of like high
school and of your childhood before you
all go off it sucks you're not allowed
to be around each other we have to take
this very seriously
but I will say like when this ends and
everybody is allowed to regather it's
gonna be a fast
Coenen and I think like all those kids
who are pent up at home they're gonna
get together and they are gonna get I
gotta say I've never been to a fest
great it's like driving a station wagon
full of fertilizer ah Wow okay okay I
missed out on that man fantastic yeah
but I am I will report back but I'm
trying to work on something for for prom
yeah but I will say like it sucks
there's no there's no denying it it
sucks for these kids but I think when we
all get back together those kids are
gonna have a good time now Olympic
dreams make sure I get the word on that
Olympic dreams is available for
streaming it's out there right now and
and this is the best time to watch
streaming content and we think this
would be the perfect time to be having a
project to come out on streaming and it
is and it's and it's a really sweet like
I think for right now especially like
it's one of those movies that's very
sweet and a little escapist at a time
when sometimes that people want to watch
different things I really I really enjoy
it and it's yeah it's streaming on all
types of stuff now I also want to
mention big mouth is currently of course
on Netflix and oh hello the podcast is
partnering with United Way this is very
cool and listeners of the podcast are
asked to donate to United Way of New
York's Co vid 19 community fund so
you're making a lot of funny stuff and
you're also you're also helping out
which is great that's a great combo
trying to yeah oh hello podcast me and
John Mulaney have been in touch with Gil
faizon and george st. geegland are the
guys who did those guys what's up what
are those guys working on what are those
guys up to they're in self quarantine
and we got a fax a Xerox copy of a fax
that was dropped in a in a deeply manila
envelope I don't think it's like it's
manila and there were there were olive
juice stains on the on the manila
envelope anyway inside of it was like we
got it the cast we're ready to go so we
have been working with our producer Lena
and in putting out a new podcast every
week from the boys from about the life
and death of Princess Diana
the boys are obsessed with right yes the
boys are obsessed with the life and
death of Princess Diana so they're
putting out a podcast about that and
they've been it being they're being
advised by Ira Glass from this American
Life and Sara canning from serial
podcast and they're trying to guide
George and Gil through this they Georgie
he'll stop making the podcast about a
year and a half ago but they want to
quote win the quarantine so they buried
their personal h't to make this podcast
so we're in it we're going to help them
get the word out it's incredible it's
incredible that in this great time of
strife for the world and America that
foolishness is still being made around
the clock what else can we do what else
can we do
I don't know make masks medicine make a
make an antiviral I was gonna do the
quarantine this morning but instead I'm
trying to help Gil faizon get the outlaw
podcast exactly well it's been really
fun talking to you I love chatting with
you and it does make me happy to know
that you are cranking away with your
team of strange people making this great
stuff always and to use well let's let's
keep chatting and and I look forward to
being in a room with you in person soon
and I'll give you the proper pass
of a greeting men which is it at UNK
it's a tongue kiss from an Irishman
that's always the proper state of
greeting I can do that hi great anyone
wants to complete the Passover miracle
I'll make that happen I promise thank
you very much Nick crawl
thanks going